heidi is in phoenix welcome to the dave
ramsey show heidi
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are you better than i deserve how
can i help
so i'm going to try and keep this short
i have 200 000 of student loan debt
and unfortunately not a doctor or lawyer
i just got a business degree from a
private school and i'm currently making
45 000 a year
just with my main job i also have two
part-time jobs i'm at a point where even
if i live on rice and beans beans and
rice it'll take me 10 years to get out
of this hole
and so i have a i have a shovel problem
and i don't really know where to go with
my career
and so i'm just kind of needing some
guidance
in where to go with my career and how i
can get out of this mess as fast as
possible okay
so you have a business degree
yes
and what are you doing today
um i am an academic financial specialist
at a university
okay
so you're not using she's also part of
the problem yeah so you're not using
your degree
correct okay all right what was your
dream when you started this um
i wanted to go into music business that
was the goal in the dream the business
side of the music business
yes
okay
um and when when are you gonna do that
i don't know that i want to um i
when i graduated i
wasn't finding anything and so
i just jumped into the first job that
full-time job that offered me money and
it was in the university
and
i have been
with universities ever since moving up
within universities
no this career tracks not working for
you
it's not
how old are you
27. okay so
the thing i asked myself i always about
me and i'm gonna ask it for you about
you is so what are you gonna be doing
when you're 37 that makes 150 000 a year
i i don't know
no i'm just saying this
that's that's what we need to aim at
because it's not the track you're on
it's not going to take you there right
it might be it might be business side of
the music business you got turned off on
that somehow
or you just got distracted trying to eat
i think mostly i just got turned off to
it and then i also got distracted
because i wasn't finding anything and
even with the connections i was making
it wasn't going anywhere so she got
turned off because of rejection
yeah okay all right that's cool
i don't blame you for that um so maybe
we broaden um so what was it about the
business side of the music business that
was attractive
to you originally
um i've always had a business mind so
i've always been very
numbers minded as well as
planning things and helping people
reach the goals that they need to meet
like why the music business
i fell in love with music and i wanted
to do
i wanted to help the artists get to
where they needed to go there you go um
and that was the passion that i had for
that good for you okay now we're talking
all right that's that's good this is
good that's perfect so there's lots of
things you can do where you help people
get where they want to go
and they can even be doing something
that you kind of are a fan of like music
or something else you could be a sports
it could be the same thing in sports
right you could help people get where
they want to go with acting or you could
help the entertainers you could help
people get them where they want to go
so
um
you know there's uh
what i want to do what i want to do is
have you pan back just a little bit i'm
thinking that your
music business the business side of
music business might have been a little
bit narrow
and that caused you to have a smaller
field from which you could get options
i might pan back i don't want to pan all
the way back and go anything in business
that's too far back because it's not
specific enough to give you a track to
run on right
but i want to pan back far enough that i
have more than two options or three
options to work for to get this going
are two or three things to do so bottom
line is you have an administrative gift
and a math gift and you see business
models in your mind like i do i'm the
same way that makes us entrepreneurial
and business-minded you have a natural
business acumen am i wrong
that's correct that sets you up to do a
whole lot of different things almost too
many different things virtually any
business part of the problem virtually
any business except what you're doing
now could utilize that
you're using none of those gifts where
you are
right and that's why you're underpaid by
double
you should be making 90 by now
okay and so i'm not picking on you i'm
just saying we got to get you back to
using your gifts because that's where
the money is for everybody
when we use it that actually gives me a
lot of hope
yeah when you get when you use your
gifts that's where you make your money
and so um and you and i have enough
things in common here that i can my
brain kind of works like yours and so i
can kind of see that so what you need to
do is is figure out like three or four
different things that touch the same
nerve
that the music business touched
for you where you can apply these gifts
in a way that helps you help people that
was a big thing so the financial
planning field you know our smartvestor
pros for instance they help people
do the exact same thing you're talking
about from a finance perspective they're
coaching them along
you could be in a situation where you're
running a business for someone
and being you know being a general
manager of
whatever
you could fall in love with construction
and uh be running the office and helping
the business run that builds houses for
people that is their dreams
i mean that's the exact same thing but
in a very different weird way but it's
touching the same nerve and using the
same gifts am i wrong
no that
you made me fall in love with all of it
yeah yeah that's so you've just got to
look at it that way now you don't want
to use your business acumen in a way
that you cannot see how people are
helped
because that will dry you up and shoot
you you won't you'll die
okay okay but you gotta you gotta be
able to see the end of it and say this
is how i use these gifts and and when i
do people are served in this way and i
see my customers smiling because i use
these gifts with this company or in this
career field and then that gets you
there ken coleman is our ramsey
personality that coaches people on
careers he does a great job he has a
podcast called the ken coleman shows
also live show on siriusxm he's a new
book coming out next week called the
proximity principle
and it's uh all the proven strategy that
will lead you to the career you love
you desperately need this book and i'm
going to send you one okay
thank you so much the stuff he talks
about in that book getting in proximity
with the people that are doing the
things you want to do and the places
where the things you want to do are
happening and defining what it is you
want to do
then you can get back on track but
you're right you have a shovel problem
you defined it properly absolutely you
have analyzed your situation you're very
self-aware you've got a good handle on
where you are you cannot stay where you
are it is not a good plan
right it's not working i mean the math
of 45 000 income plus extra jobs with a
200 000 student loan that math is very
very hopeless
yeah and the good news is you don't have
to stay there
right and it may it may take you a year
to get this fixed and get the income
going but at least let's get on track to
where the 37 year old you looks back at
the 27 year old you and it goes way to
go girl
okay hold on i'm gonna have kelly pick
up we're gonna send you a copy of the
book the proximity principle we'll get
it to you